[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Most Flutter
widgets are boxes.
You can lay them out,
stack them, even nest them
inside each other.
But what happens when that one
box doesn't fit in the other?
To help with that,
there's FittedBox.
Just give it a child
widget and a BoxFit that
describes how it should
make its child fit,
and it will scale or clip
its child automatically.
The BoxFit enum offers a
bunch of different fit types,
like fitWidth,
fill, and even none.
There is also an
alignment property
that tells FittedBox how to
align the child if there's
extra space.
For more info on FittedBox and
all the other Flutter widgets,
head to Flutter.io.
[MUSIC PLAYING]